pour notre détour par les archives
aujourd'hui on révisait un pan de
l'histoire agricole au pays
le déclin de la production de tabac
pendant des années cette plante a fait
les beaux jours des agriculteurs
notamment en ontario la plus grande
région productrice au pays
mais dans ce reportage de 1989 on sent
la fin d'une époque
reportage qui débute d'ailleurs par une
mise en scène étonnante
[Musique]
alors
le plaisir de la nicotine un plaisir qui
a perdu beaucoup de popularité au cours
des dernières dix années car des études
tendent à démontrer qu'il peut sur noise
mans se transformer en crise m en cancer
ou un problème cardiaque
ce nouveau courant pro santé constitue
un tournant dramatique pour l'industrie
du tabac la consommation de cigarettes
diminuant de quelques pour cent chaque
année a forcé plusieurs tabaculteurs à
abandonner cette production
en ontario le nombre de producteurs est
passé de 2500 au début des années 80 à
1300 de nos jours soit la moitié moins
la plupart de ceux qui ont quitté
l'industrie ont trouvé d'autres emplois
la majorité ne sont plus agriculteurs
certains ont essayé des cultures
différentes ce qui a tourné à l'échec et
dans bien des cas ils ont fait
banqueroute
beaucoup d'anciens tabaculteurs
conduisent maintenant des camions ou
travail telle usine et certains sont
sans emploi
pourtant il n'ya pas si longtemps les
producteurs de tabac faisait l'envi de
tous dans cette production ont rapporté
bien quand pierre dion a commencé dans
l'industrie du tabac à l'âge de 17 ans
c'était payant même un titre d'ouvrier
il gagnait 8 dollars par jour alors que
pour son travail de cuisinier au québec
et le récolté un maigre 20 $ pour une
semaine de 60 heures autant le tabac
représente ait un avenir prometteur il
ya 15 20 ans autant aujourd'hui le tabac
lui pèse comme boulet à la cheville
c'était difficile de rester dans le
tableau parce que c'est beaucoup plus
dur
du bonheur pour faire livrer les banques
sont très durs pour avoir des emprunts
de chauffage qui y voient d'abord
diminuer
c'est très très difficile de continuer
la baisse du tabagisme au fil des ans
est l'une des causes du déclin de cette
culture dans les années 60 la moitié des
adultes canadiens fumée en 1990 ce
n'était plus que le tiers
mais la concurrence internationale a
aussi fait mal
le tabac canadien était de bonne qualité
mais il était parmi les plus chères au
monde
[Musique]
c'est sûr que le concurrencer d'autres
pays producteurs croissance c'est un
problème parce qu'ils peuvent produire
du tabac pour moins cher qu'ici au
canada ils peuvent engager un ouvrier
pour 30 dollars alors que le même ouvrir
soit ici 100 dollars la journée ou
presque
empruntés aux autochtones la culture du
tabac sur une base commerciale remonte
aux années 1800 dans le sud de l'ontario
pendant longtemps cette culture aura
apporté prospérité à cette petite
bourgade
aujourd'hui les producteurs ont presque
honte de mentionner qu'ils sont à la
culture
quant à leur avenir la partie est loin
d'être gagnée on craint que plusieurs
doivent encore quitter la production du
tabac au fil des ans beaucoup de
producteurs de tabac ont accepté des
subventions pour se tourner vers
d'autres cultures leurs terres
sablonneuses étant d'ailleurs idéale
pour la production de pommes de terre éd
asperges notamment au québec dans la
région de lanaudière qu'on surnommait
autrefois le pays du tabac il ne reste
plus qu'un seul producteur
en ontario on en compte encore 150